[Musique]
on
jeux d'eau mais vous n'aimez pas qu'on
vous appelle monsieur non madame je veux
qu'on m'appelle bébert l'appui pourquoi
parce que albert est un nom de guerre le
diminutif la pipe comme j'ai toujours au
bec ça veut plus intimes boyer et bien
le dévers où est tourné à perpignan le
11 juillet 1920 et le 20 août 1944 vous
étiez à paris racontez-nous votre
journée du 20 août 22 44 j'étais dans
l'écho front de la préfecture de police
nous étions 8 nous avions déjà navigué
depuis plusieurs jours le 20 au matin
j'ai eu un camarade qui a été tué le
long de la seine le matin à 11h jeu
grenade est en train de péniche du pont
d'austerlitz l'après midi nous devions
aller chercher des munitions rue des
morillons dans un garage la préfecture
de police manquant de munitions le set
qui reste ion du confort sont allés
là-bas cobaye est très zen avec une
vieille traction
nous étions 5 da et un sur l'ale le
soutiennent et à rester à la préfecture
dernièrement devant recevoir des ordres
du préfet de police de l'époque et
comment saviez-vous que il y avait des
munitions c'étaient les renseignements
par d'autres agents n'est ce pas qui
nous avait dit là bas il ya des
munitions qui sont gardés karl par des
territoriaux par des vieux nous sommes
arrivés devant ce garage est surprise
une vingtaine dressait ce nous attendait
on avait été vendu par qui on ne sait
pas non vous attendez on a été fait
immédiatement encerclé on nous a fait
descendre des véhicules tous les six
tous les suisses dans le 5e et le celui
qui était sur l'aide de la voiture a
réussi à s'échapper nous étions dedans
moi n'a pas pu c'est le fameux de
longues on n'a pas retrouvé depuis je ne
sais pas ce qu'il est devenu et tous les
saints qui reste ion on nous a mis
contre le mur
dans le garage contre le mur le fait de
belles interroge notre chef chevrier lui
demandant de venir vous faire ici lui
diplomate a dit nous sommes une
patrouille de police pour rétablir
l'ordre n'est ce pas nous patrouillons
mais ça n'a pas pris les armes et bien
entendu jamais moi personnellement une
musette pleine de grenade et les autres
y avait ce qu'il fallait ça n'a pas pris
le fait webber a pris le téléphone qui
avait dans le bureau à côté a demandé d
ordre
les ordres étaient de réfugiés je ne
comprenais pas du tout l'allemand est à
côté de moi j'avais un jeune fille ni
daury qui comprenait un peu l'allemand
et il me dit on vient de lui téléphoner
de nos fusillés
et à ce moment là ça s'est passé très
vite
le fait tribal a aligné une douzaine de
grands hommes à me réfugier on nous a
prêté et au moment de commander feu j'ai
un réflexe de vieux militaire qui a agi
je suis tombé
avant qu'il n'ait tiré parce qu'en tant
donnant commandement avant que le
cerveau a enregistré le doit juste se
passer des dizaines de secondes et j'ai
profité de sa crèche puis tomber les
ballons sont passés au dessus et j'ai
quatre corps qui nous sont tombés dessus
à quatre autres et les carottes ne sont
pas rien qui n'est pas mort sur le coup
on nous a achevés à la grenade les
cadavres non protégés et en maintenant
après il a 20 qui râlent et je les ai
sentis qui frémissait mais on est venu
l'achever il n'a plus bougé cela se
passait vers 8h 8h30 du soir et je suis
restée toute la nuit sous les cadavres
sans bouger
le jeu suit j'étais état de grenade au
coup de grâce au gel plus tard et au
saumon plantée dans le bras gauche et
j'ai pris des éclats de grenade le
lendemain 21 quand j'ai vu le jour se
lever j'ai tenté le tout pour le tout
mais je peux pas rester là éternellement
je ne pouvais pas parce que je ne
connaissais pas le coin il faisait noir
je ne sais pas si la porte était fermée
les allemands étaient toujours allemand
était encerclé par les chutes de
vaugirard il me sort ils étaient à
l'intérieur étaient à l'intérieur du
garage volets voilier
je les entends d re mue par une voix il
rien exposé nu et ce n'est qu'au lever
du jour le mal le matin j'ai vu le jour
se pointer sous le bras j'ai vu la porte
ouverte est une sentinelle j'ai glissé
tout doucement sous les cadavres je me
suis levé d'un seul bond et j'ai foncé
la salle isation prix négatifs se sont
ressaisis m'ont tiré dessus et là j'ai
été blessé vous mangez une balle qui m'a
traversé et dendre à en tirer sur les
hommes en croyant à une sortie les ffi
m'ont blessé au mollet droit j'ai pris
une balle française en même temps j'ai
descendu la rue des morillons g première
tournée à première vue à gauche pour
inviter les vannes des allemands
j'ai tourné la première rue à droite je
faisais mon petit slalom si vous voyez
et là je suis tomber d'épuisement
et j'entends qu'on courait derrière moi
je me suis relevé je retournais une rue
à gauche à la première maison je suis
tombé j'ai tapé en amont semble
intéresser plusieurs juments de
plusieurs semaines sur la porte on a
ouvert en matière est dans le couloir et
dans ce couloir et des gens parler moi
j'étais un peu dans le cirage et je me
rappelle une chose on appelait une dame
qui habitait dans les étages une
s'appuie sur le deuxième ou le troisième
pour venir voir cette dame est une
infirmière elle m'a tout fait une piqûre
pour retenir le coeur elle a appelé par
sa fenêtre l'hôpital vaugirard qui était
de l'autre côté de la rue les
brancardiers sont venus mon âme n'est
pas la petite porte s'était pas l'entrée
des artistes malheureusement à la radio
les allemands à les allemands étaient
arrêtés par les faits il y avait des
tirs de barrage et s'est rallumée de
partout ce qui m'a permis la guérison
perdu ma trace
combien vaut une radiologue en
permanence 24 heures sur 24
immédiatement le passé à la radio et on
a opéré j'ai été opéré par le professeur
sénèque agira il ya très longtemps je
suis resté un mois à l'hôpital
alors j'ai eu le plaisir de revoir cette
dame madame projet d'art tu viendras
gérard qui est venu me rendre visite à
l'hôpital plusieurs fois ainsi que
d'autres personnes du quartier j'étais
la vedette et du 15e arrondissement tout
le monde revenait avec des gâteries
pas oublié mais je suis intelligent
quand même un mauvais inuits et jours on
avait peur d'eux n'est pas un choix je
les ai eu d'ailleurs
c'était grave on sait pas comment je
m'en tirerais je m'en suis bien tiré
vous voyez vous m'avez écrit que de sept
pétales vous gardiez surtout un souvenir
le meilleur a le meilleur the wiz optio
le meilleur c'est la visite d'un ancien
combattant avec sa fille qui venait
apporter une bonne bouteille au réservé
pour le mariage de la fille ayant
considéré que ce que j'avais fait plus
pour que le mariage il m'a offert cette
bouteille les larmes aux yeux bien
entendu et ceci m'a beaucoup plus
touchés que les propositions décoration
comme a fait que je n'ai jamais eu
autant
je ne fais pas d'illusion rugby je n'ai
rien à [ __ ] en tout cas vous m'avez
écrit que cette dame madame pidaf qui
vous a fait une piqûre qui vous a fait
transporter à l'hôpital de vaugirard que
vous vouliez retrouver alors par les
modèles mais cette dame que j'ai connu
par la suite quelques jours guindé venu
me rendre visite
me disais qu elles sont hors était
prisonnier de guerre étaient polonais
elle avait une petite fillette d'une
douzaine d'années environ et cette dame
était infirmière mais pas dans les
services de vaugirard je ne me suis
jamais renseigné à quel hôpital l été
mais si je suis en vie c'est grâce à
elle est passée les pros second c'est lé
cas tous les endroits on m'avait dit que
vous aviez lancé des appels dans des
journaux oui j'ai eu mon disque du
souvenir il fut un temps d'un projet
d'un un souvenir de son mari puisque
c'était la chanson de prisonniers à
l'époque des prisonniers de guerre ça
sent si bon la france eh bien monsieur
demain
j'oubliais qu'il fallait vous appelez
blé vers la paix loin percée des verts
la plaie vous êtes venu d'andorre
24 ans presque jour pour jour
anniversaire 19 août 20 coups puis dans
l'espoir de rencontrer madame pj daïeff
et non pas projet d'agencé de 24 ans et
de lui dire merci vous allez l'avoir
tout à l'heure dites moi puisque vous
recherchez madame poggi d'ailleurs vous
allez la voir bientôt
décrivez là telle qu'elle est restée
dans votre mémoire dans ma mémoire je
vois une dame brune moyenne 1 m 60 65
une corpulence moyenne également c'est
assez vague voyez les yeux
non il me semble
pouvait pas être certain nous allons
voir si vous avez raison ou pas puisque
avant de la voir en chair et en os vous
allez si vous voulez écouter et regarder
avec nous le récit qu'elle nous a fait
lorsque nous sommes allés la voir à issy
les moulineaux le récit qui se rapporte
à votre histoire alors il nous reste à
nous rendre rue adolphe chérioux à issy
les moulineaux and image à regarder
[Musique]
positif madame ses talons russe oui oui
madame mon mari est d'origine russe et
vous même ah non moi je suis un guignol
vous vous souvenez très bien de
l'histoire d'albert domec et pour cause
pour vous cette histoire commence le 20
août 1944 sur votre chemin de retour
depuis la mairie du xvème jusqu'à la rue
vaux cela sera compté 17 exergue ses
utilisations des souvenirs qu'on
n'oublie pas à ce moment là je me
souviens qu'il y avait le couvre-feu
imposé par les allemands et puis ce soir
là le bruit avait couru que le
couvre-feu il n'existait plus
tout le monde était dans la rue nous
sommes allés à la mairie du 15e pour
connaître les nouvelles je sais que la
police était en grève n'y avait pas de
policier à la mairie du xvème les ffi
tenez la mairie l'église fermée d'impôt
français qui flottait nous disent mais
rentrée il ne restait pas duel que
veuves existe rentrez chez vous bon
alors j'étais avec une amie et ma petite
fille qui avait 11 ans et demi à
l'époque nous venions chez nous montions
la ville est riche il est arrivé chez
nous de bouger là et je joue notre
parcours une voiture arrive à toute
vitesse et nous dépasse en montant cette
tenue est vu l'udemo lyon il y avait un
garage sur la gauche qui était occupé
par les allemands ça nous le savions
mais on pensait qu'il n'en restait
presque plus l'allemand comment ça s'est
passé exactement nous n'étions pas
encore à la hauteur de la voiture mais
quand nous sommes arrivés au bout de la
rue nous avons vu les français qui
étaient dans la voiture qui était sorti
je ne sais pas s'il ya eu une explosion
à ce moment je crois bien que les
allemands ont jeté une grenade dans
l'ain dans la voiture il peut nous avons
vu nous nous français les bras en l'air
et emmené dans ce garage comme
nous en avons vu plusieurs mon avis 4 ou
5 vous savez autant qu'on puisse compter
comme sont des événements dramatiques
comme ça oh mon dieu qu'est-ce qui va
arriver immédiatement entendu car clac
clac savez les mitrailleuses alors nous
étions retournez-vous décès j'étais avec
une amie
j'étais aux folles enfin la nuit s'est
passée on entend des détonations
j'ai pas dormi
le matin m'a usée nuit encore pourtant
une très grosse encore d'aider les coups
de feu qui après une jacques jose d'état
nation je me lève j'ouvre la fenêtre je
regarde et nuit il pleuvait et nuit et
toutes étaient mille play lors je vois
une eau qui sonné à toutes les portes
moi je pensais au aux événements de la
veille
et à ce moment-là à une autre porte la
nôtre la porte après nous c'est à lyon
c'était au 13 j'entends bublé je vous en
conjure suis blessé moi je dis vous ne
bougez pas je des singes 12 pouvoir
mélanger ce que j'ai fait j'ai sur deux
mais trois étages et puis j'ai ouvert la
tribune de la porte puisqu'il n'y avait
pas besoin d'eux il y avait quatre
listes et un portable bataille avec la
transfère s'il y avait la concierge mais
probablement tout le monde était sourd
il y avait peut-être que moi qui avais
entendu les détonations je ne sais pas
en tout cas personne ne voulait ouvrir
même je ne veux rien dire mais je me
suis fait attraper parce que je voulais
un rôle important passons j'avais peur
alors j'ai ouvert la porte ce garçon est
entrée s'est effondré il était plein de
sang gicle morts alors j'ai fait un
rapprochement avec la fusillade de la
veille est alors je lui dis est ce que
vous étiez dans la voiture je dis oui
j'étais dans la voiture est tous mes
camarades sont morts mais noir qu'est ce
que je pouvais faire doute alors les
gens sont venus sont descendus des
étages
moi je ne savais pas soigner un blessé
blue j'étais bien embarrassé au fond
chic il était à la vie c'est tout
n'étiez pas infirmiers à nous j'avais
une amie infirmière dans la maison parce
que dans la maison m'a dit que vous avez
cette infirmière et demi parce que vous
allez nominaux ils se trouvent non
malheureusement je n'étais pas
infirmière mais j'ai une amie qui est
infirmière qui habitait au quatrième
étage qui est descendu alors elle lui a
donné les premiers soins je croyais
l'adie série sa ceinture elle lui a fait
une piqûre et alors elle connaissait
elle habite elle était justement
l'hôpital de bougies rares elles et nous
n'en étions séparés que par l'autre vous
savez les portes de service de l'hôpital
de vaugirard était en face notre
immeuble alors elle connaissait
évidemment le personnel de l'hôpital
elle est remontée chez elle au quatrième
elle a appelé
par la fenêtre oui alors après bien des
palabres ils ont ouvert la porte à
l'hôpital de vaugirard ils sont venus
avec une civière et il en lice manolo
gars sont malins moi je savais ce qu'il
avait dit que il était le seul rescapé
tous ses camarades étaient morts et moi
j'avais vu qu'il y en avait quand même
quatre ou cinq on fait plus tard dans la
matinée je suis allée à l'hôpital de
meaux gérard parce que moi j'ai cru
qu'il allait mourir
une balle qui lui avait passé lui
dépasser entre le poumon et fois il a
une chance inespérée et alors l'après
midi on m'a permis d'aller le voir
l'ontarien peux pas me couper après
milieu nous sommes allés viande et des
visites etc après c'était la libération
de paris tout s'est bien passé que vous
prenez vous alors je ne sais pas par la
suite on a perdu sa trace je crois qu'il
est allé on armée d'occupation en
allemagne pourtant il avait notre
adresse je ne sais pas on a perdu sa
trace après il veut la faire d'une
adresse que jean bleu nous avons
déménagé en suisse comprenez vous c'est
pour ça qu'il m'a écrit pour me demander
de votre à retrouver parce qu'il estime
que c'est à vous qu'il doit c'est-à-dire
que si on l'avait laissé dehors
peut-être que son avec son hémorragie il
rachète est resté c'est possible enfin
peut-être que quelqu'un ne voudrais pas
faire ramasser ouvrir la porte quand
même il faut pas exagérer
vous l'avez reconnu
voyez elle se souvient de votre histoire
aussi bien que vous en souvenez vous
même en très madame choisit d'ailleurs
si si c'est vrai des caméras parce que
le jour de noël nous avons vieilli tous
les démons trouve 34 ans mais vous venez
vous vise à faire là bas
je porte un peu mieux oui pauvre la
recette est triste de se dire oui on les
oublie pas on aurait interrogé vingt ans
plus tard je reviendrai
elle a les yeux bleus les
témoignages
oui oui moi je vous connais me suis dit
qu évidemment plus
j'ai pris quelques kilos de plus
et votre petite fille la petite filière
35 ans maintenant et là deux petites
filles moi je suis clairement énoncé on
perd 2 ans perd aussi deux fois
séparément
[Musique]